[Music]
clever girl
hey there fellow film buffs i'm mark
ellis and welcome to a dynomite new
episode of rt essentials it's gonna be
good times because this one goes out to
all you dinosaur fanatics out there you
know the wannabe paleontologists we know
who you are you're the ones that buy up
all that jurassic park mercs the
t-shirts the lunch boxes the screeching
t-rex toy with realistic dinosaur skin
whatever that means you just can't get
enough of the dino craze can you uh p.s
if you have any jurassic park toys for
sale please let me know i'm asking for a
friend not named me anyways did you know
that dinosaur is a combination of greek
words that directly translate to
terrible wizard and tyrannosaurus rex
translates to king of the tyrant lizards
which also happens to be my band name
not really but you know one can dream
the bottom line is this people are
obsessed with anything and everything
dinosaur especially the movie and today
we're shining a light on the films that
feature our favorite prehistoric
reptilian tyrants
heroes these are the best dinosaur
movies the land before time who are you
huh my name's petrie
petrie huh funny name
i i flied no
you falled i fall
and up first is the land before time an
animated adventure directed and produced
by don bluth who's also responsible for
the film all dogs go to heaven which if
we ever do an episode about terrifying
dog animated movies that one's gonna be
near the top of the list anyways the
land before time is the tale of little
foot a young apothesaurus who prefers
vegetables and is orphaned after his
mother perishes while protecting him
from a vicious t-rex as littlefoot's
mother was dying she told her
long-necked son how to get to the great
valley an area that has been spared from
devastation and where he can reunite
with the others of his kind while on his
journey to the great valley littlefoot
befriends four new companions ducky the
cyrolophus sarah the triceratops petri
the pteranodon and spike the stegosaurus
did i pronounce those names right let's
cross our fingers the dynamic group must
endure a series of hardships worst of
all being tracked by sharp tooth the
same t-rex that killed littlefoot's
mother
sarah
you're back
now i'll admit this film's timeline a
little suspect some of the species that
interact throughout the movie are in
reality separated by up to 80 million
years of evolutionary time meaning they
weren't even close to ever coexisting so
let me put this in perspective there's
less time between a human and a t-rex
than there is a t-rex like sharp tooth
and a stegosaurus like spike and though
we've all wept over littlefoot's tragic
loss of his mother research has shown
that sauropods most likely laid their
eggs and left them which means that
littlefoot would have never even known
his mother but despite the film's
adulterous themes and heartbreaking
content it's still made for the kiddos
so i think we can put aside the
scientific inaccuracies for the sake of
fun no need to get all jack horner on it
he's the world's most famous
paleontologist not to be confused with
james horner who actually composed the
music for the land before time and it
all comes together those two are not
related dinosaurs
dinosaur was disney's 39th animated
feature and followed aledar an iguanodon
who was raised by a family of lemurs on
a tropical island things are going
smoothly as smoothly as the world filled
with giant lizards being raised by
monkeys could go but suddenly everything
is turned upside down when meteors
strike and their lush habitat is turned
into a desert wasteland aldar must team
up with a herd of other herbivores and
journey to the nesting ground where
water and vegetation are plentiful but
pesky carnivores like the carnotaurus
are always close behind and aladdar and
his friends must watch their backs or
else find themselves on the menu
hang on
the film was actually conceived back in
the 80s by visual effects producer phil
tippett and acclaimed director paul
verhoeven the two were working on
robocop at the time and tippett
mentioned his idea for a movie about
dinosaurs which got verhoven excited and
soon the two were pitching said idea to
jeffrey katzenberg then president of
disney a budget was put together and it
was off to the races until some creative
differences ensued as they often do
something along the lines of verhoven
and tippit wanting to make a darker more
violent movie that was rumored to be
featuring and i quote huge battles with
geysers of blood and dinosaurs pooping
and ripping each other's heads off not
exactly what fans of the little mermaid
and bambi would have expected to see so
tippet and beerhoven departed from the
project and after years of development
hell the film was finally greenlit by
then disney ceo michael eisner and
animation officially began in 1997
unfortunately without the dino droppings
and or severed heads dinosaur was
released in may of 2000 and became the
fifth highest grossing film of the year
additionally it was praised for its
spectacular visuals and vocal
performances the good dinosaurs
what makes a dinosaur good well ask arlo
the apothesaurus from pixar's the good
dinosaur actually don't ask arlo because
he's probably afraid of difficult
questions considering he's afraid of
everything under the sun which is why
it's especially disconcerting when a
rainstorm washes poor arlo down river
and he ends up bruised battered and
miles away from his family and home but
when arlen meets and befriends a small
neanderthal boy named spot the unlikely
duo embark on an epic adventure to
reunite arlo with his family i can say
with complete confidence that arlo is in
fact a good dinosaur unlike that bad
dinosaur shark tooth from the land
before time that's right i called out
shark tooth what's he going to do tweet
at me i got a real bone to pick with you
dino dad jokes the good dinosaur was
directed by peter song and featured the
voice talents of jeffrey wright steve
zahn anna paquin and many others
um
son wanted to make a coming-of-age film
which is why he decided to tinker with
the original concept which saw arlo as
an immature adult and instead make him
an awkward clumsy petrified 11 year old
son has also stated that though the
film's title is simple it has a lot more
meaning than it seems to that's all well
and good but uh really i'm still p.o to
sharptube the good dinosaur received
generally positive reviews with the
atlantic writing that it breaks new
ground for pixar in that it's the
studio's first feature that is
explicitly and pretty much exclusively a
kids movie npr even likened the
animation to thomas hill paintings and
panoramic widescreen some critics did
complain that the storytelling wasn't up
to pixar standards but they're just
dinosaur losers
i'll be here all week unless they fire
me
king kong
all right before you start going ape and
accusing king kong of not belonging on
this list let's just keep in mind that
any film featuring dinosaurs of any kind
in any role is eligible to be labeled a
dinosaur movie don't believe me look it
up in the thesaurus
i got so many of these peter jackson's
king kong is an expansive remake of the
1933 classic and follows director carl
denham and his crew as they journey from
new york city to skull island to film a
new movie that movie stars vaudeville
actress anne darrow who gets whisked
away by the natives of the island and is
offered as a sacrifice to the giant
gorilla kong but kong doesn't kill her
instead he takes an interest in her and
anne though terrified begins to grasp
kong's intelligence and emotional
capacity yada yada one thing leads to
another i know get to the dinosaurs and
here we go as the film crew organizes a
rescue party for anne they find
themselves caught between a herd of
apothesaurus and a pack of t-rex
ugh
all right now let me take a second to
clarify something since i'm dealing with
some real dinosaur connoisseurs here
they aren't actually supposed to be a
t-rex in the film they're actually
called what is known as a the
statusaurus rex a fictional evolved
descendant of the t-rex and they're
found exclusively if you act now on
skull island jackson was very deliberate
about making this distinction but i mean
come on if it looks like a t-rex and
acts like a t-rex and dances like a
t-rex i'm just kidding there's no
dancing dinos in this film keywords in
this film hold that thought king kong
went on to win three oscars best sound
editing best sound mixing and best
visual effects it also grossed over
560 million dollars at the box office
and garnered mostly positive reviews
jurassic world
good
darling
stay right there
good
close the gate
are you crazy hey just trust me close
the
again
[Music]
jurassic world is proof that the allure
of dinosaurs outweighs the risk
considering that this is the fourth
installment in the jurassic park
franchise you think everyone would have
learned their lesson by now humans and
dinosaurs were just not meant to
co-exist but it's just such a fun
concept and it makes a lot of money and
executive producer steven spielberg
decided to switch things up in this
installment by toying with the idea of a
dinosaur park that actually get this
functions meaning no t-rex biting
lawyers heads off while they're on the
toilets more on that later the jurassic
world luxury resort is located off the
coast of costa rica and it provides a
habitat for an array of genetically
engineered dinosaurs notably the vicious
and intelligent indominus rex naturally
the massive creature escapes which sets
off a chain reaction that causes many of
the other dinos to run amok now a former
military man and animal expert must
utilize their special set of skills to
save the park's tourists from an all-out
prehistoric assault what's that thing i
said about being a functioning dinosaur
park they had a jimmy buffett's
margaritaville there once again for my
connoisseurs the indominus rex is a
fictional dinosaur that was created for
this film
it's sort of a hybrid of a t-rex a
velociraptor a dash of other species a
hint of teeth meaning it's extremely
fast has an incredibly strong bite
possesses a high level of intelligence
and can camouflage itself this leads me
to one very important question for all
the scientists who are currently working
in the jurassic world dino dna
department
what the heck were you thinking they
were probably thinking that people would
really want to see this magnificent
creature and i can't say that they were
wrong jurassic world grossed 1.6 billion
dollars in box office revenue becoming
the third highest grossing film of
all time at that time anyway
additionally two sequels have been
produced one in 2018 and jurassic world
dominion in 2022 ice age 3 dawn of the
dinosaurs
[Music]
[Applause]
ice age dawn of the dinosaurs is the
third installment in the popular ice age
film series and follows our favorite
animated sloth sid who just can't seem
to stay out of trouble this time he's
really done it he's stolen the eggs of a
female tyrannosaurus who in turn takes
it and her newly hatched dino babies
underground so now manny the wooly
mammoth diego the saber-tooth tiger and
the rest of their prehistoric crew must
enter the mysterious and dangerous
underworld to rescue their silly sloth
friend the film featured the voice
talents of ray romano john leguizamo and
queen latifah and was directed by carlos
saldana now i know what you're thinking
willie mammoth and t-rex they never even
came close to sharing time and space on
this planet but guess what uh sloths
don't really talk did you know that and
magical underworlds filled with lush
vegetation and thriving jurassic beasts
would never manage to actually exist
under a frozen tundra like it does in
the film bring it on you chicken-headed
[Music]
the filmmakers were well aware of these
blaring contradictions and opted to move
forward anyways once again for the sake
of entertainment and because i mean come
on dinosaurs are cool and i appreciate
any movie that tries to throw some
dinosaurs in wherever it can even at the
expense of scientific accuracy
ice age dawn of the dinosaurs was
released in july of 2009 and was the
first 20th century fox film to be
released in 3d it became the third
highest grossing film of the year really
people loved that squirrel and it was
the highest grossing movie in the entire
franchise though the critical reception
was overall mixed empire magazine called
it an enjoyable yarn for the most part
and the independent uk wrote that it
will do as holiday entertainment for
children who liked the first two not
exactly rave reviews but hey that
animation pretty fantastic we're back a
dinosaur story new york city you [ __ ]
hi my name's dweeb
i'm woo
i'm elsa the name's rex what's yours i
think my name's louie but seeing you is
giving me doubts about my brain remember
that comment i made about a film with
dancing dinosaurs well welcome to where
back a dinosaur story an animated
adventure comedy based on the 1987
hudson talbot children's book of the
same name the film follows four
fun-loving dinosaurs who take a trip to
new york city courtesy of captain new
eyes
how exactly did dinosaurs end up there
well old new eyes invented a cereal that
has the power to anthropomorphize
animals he then hired an alien named
borb to go back in time and capture said
dinosaurs give them the cereal and send
them back to the present day after all
that the fab four tyrannosaurus rex
triceratops lube pterodactyl elsa and
hadrosaur dweeb were finally ready to
hit the big apple in style
you really should have called that movie
rex in the city again i'm here all week
now the other person you should know
about is my brother
professor screw eyes
he's cruel he's insane he travels around
down in this time causing mischief he
was driven mad by the loss of his eye
long ago
my advice to you is
find dr bleeb and stay well clear of my
dark and unhappy brother
storyboarding for word back began in
1990 with steven spielberg signed on as
an executive producer through his
company amblemation this feels like a
good time to point out that spielberg
had his claws in four of the films on
this list including the land before time
also we're back came out in 1993 which
is the same year another really
important spielberg dinosaur movie came
out i can't put my finger on what it was
called but maybe we get to it at some
point in this episode for now we're back
to
we're back this family-friendly dino
flick featured the vocal talents of john
goodman jay leno ria pearlman and many
others and though it's a seriously fun
time again did i say dancing dinosaurs
go to new york and the voice acting and
animation were superb the film was
overall a commercial and critical let
down it makes you feel bad for spielberg
because all he wanted to do was release
a successful film about dinosaurs in
1993 and workback just didn't work so i
think the guy's out of luck right
king kong
[Music]
next up is the original king kong
released in march of 1933
ah we were so young and directed by
marion c cooper and ernest b shudsack
this film was truly a game changer in
more ways than we have time to discuss
but notably the pioneering special
effects by willis o'brien which became
the industry standard following this
movie's release o'brien brought kong and
the numerous prehistoric creatures
inhabiting skull island to life using
models stop-motion animation traveling
mats and miniature rear projections all
these tactics were painstakingly
difficult at the time despite how they
may appear to us now almost
90 years later the iconic fight scene
between kong and the t-rex took over
seven weeks to be completed it combined
live actors and stop motion plus actress
fay ray who plays a protagonist and had
to spend 22 hours sitting in a fake tree
acting out her observation and reaction
of the dino gorilla duel
but the real dino sorcery was wielded to
accomplish the sequence where kong
fights the tanestropheus in its lair
this scene utilized a miniature set
stop-motion animation for kong real
water background map paintings four
ground rocks with bubbling mud smoke and
two miniature rear screen projections of
anne and the character driscoll
that's a tremendous amount of work for
such a brief scene but a film with giant
creatures requires giant efforts king
kong has been consistently listed as one
of the greatest horror films of all time
and in 1991 it was selected by the
library of congress for preservation in
the national film registry who cited its
cultural historical and aesthetic
significance a sequel was released the
same year and two remakes were
subsequently released one in 1976 and
then of course what we talked about
already did you do your homework peter
jackson's in 2005 the valley of guangzhi
the valley of guangzhi is a fantasy
western directed by jim o'connelly and
produced by charles h schneer and ray
harryhausen it's the story of a wild
west showman who along with his cowboys
finds dinosaurs near a mexican town and
puts them on display getting kong vibes
which isn't surprising because the story
of guangzhi was originally conceived by
willis o'brien the king kong special
effects wizard i was just raving about
o'brien was inspired by sir arthur conan
doyle's book the lost world and of
course weaved in elements of the king
kong plot you know the whole capturing
giant prehistoric creatures and bringing
them to civilization for financial gains
scheme that old racket
[Music]
[Music]
o'brien worked hard on this project
throughout the 1940s with rko pictures
originally backing it but ultimately
canceling the production because
research had shown that the public
didn't want to see a picture about
dinosaurs hold on a second are we
talking about this planet earth there
was a time when the masses of people on
this planet didn't want to see dinosaur
movies what did they want to see oh
right right more movies about monkeys
and that's exactly what o'brien made for
rko instead mighty joe young and he
abandoned guangzhi it wasn't until the
late 60s that o'brien's protege ray
harryhausen decided to revive the story
of guangzhi buying the rights from
o'brien's widow yes sadly o'brien didn't
live to see his baby come to life not
unlike the dinosaurs themselves who
didn't live to see their time in the
spotlight even the valley of guangzhi
received generally positive reviews with
most of the praise focused on the
special effects
jurassic park
and now welcome to the moment you've all
been waiting for and frankly expecting
stop writing that angry letter the movie
that's been consistently hailed as the
greatest dino film of them all and
really one of the greatest movies ever
you know the one that spawned theme park
rides in endless merchandise video games
comic books sequels the one that
reignited the world's obsession with our
ancient reptilian friends drum roll
please the movie is
barney's great adventure a kids musical
comedy based on the tvs i'm kidding
we're obviously talking about steven
spielberg's monumental blockbuster
jurassic park the first installment in
the wildly popular film franchise based
on michael crichton's novel of the same
name it follows paleontologist duo alan
grant and ellie sadler who are among a
select group chosen to tour an iowan
theme park populated by dinosaurs
created from prehistoric dna the park's
mastermind billionaire john hammond
assures everyone that the park is safe
however that riled up t-rex and the herd
of pete velaza raptors who can unlock
doors aren't really selling this whole
park is safe notion now are they john oh
and who could forget the mathematician
ian malcolm played by jeff goldblum who
specializes in chaos theory and the
physics behind using as few shirt
buttons as possible the true magic of
this picture cannot be easily summarized
we can spend an entire episode just
talking about what makes it so special
from the groundbreaking cgi by
industrial light and magic to the
sweeping john williams score to the
breathtaking scenery much of which was
shot on various hawaiian islands the
dialogue is witty consists of countless
memorable moments
stick
you like stupid stick
and no wonder you're extinct
i'm gonna run you over when i come back
down
and memeable quotes like when malcolm
pointly remarks to hammond your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they just stop
to think if they should but more than
anything spielberg brought dinosaurs to
life in a way that no movie ever had
sparing no expense to get their
mannerisms sounds shapes and behavior as
close to scientifically accurate as
possible spielberg even hired jack
horner to work as a paleontology
consultant on the film
jurassic park was released in june of
1993. i saw it five times that summer
and became the highest grossing film
ever at the time additionally it won
three academy awards and received
unanimous praise from both audiences and
critics and there you have it our
selections for the best dinosaur movies
ever i know you're all especially
passionate about this particular subject
unlike audiences in the 40s so if we
missed a film that you think deserved to
be on this list don't go calling to try
sarah cops there's plenty more episodes
of rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll get there soon enough thank
you so much for tuning in i'm mark ellis
and please never forget these four words
of wisdom wife finds a way
[Music]
[Music]